good evening welcome to another evening
at live talks Los Angeles by a show of
hands I'm always curious how many of you
are at one of our events for the very
first time Wow welcome we're glad you're
here we have your email address we are
in touch once or twice a week sometimes
we have new events to announce and hope
you'll stay with us if not ask off the
list because we hate you to miss events
anyway thanks to new road school
wonderful partners of ours we host a
bunch of our events in the space and we
have some guests in new roads school so
a special welcome to you I'm just gonna
run through there's been a very busy
fall for us just some upcoming events
and and then we'll get into the program
next this Sunday we have a version of
our series we call it the newer voices
series and we have a terrific first-time
novelist C Morgan Bapst as a new novel
and she'll be talking about that the
floating world set in Katrina time that
takes place at the Santa Monica Public
Library it's free that's what these
events are we want to especially with
debut authors give you no excuse not to
give them a chance and come in here
their work Monday night Chris Matthews
comes to our stage he has a new book out
Bobby Kennedy a raging spirit he'll be
interviewed by Frank Buckley who's one
of the morning hosts on KTLA and Tuesday
night Tim O'Reilly is with us he's has a
new book out titled wut WTF question
mark what's the future and why it's up
to us he's a technology prognosticator
and then we have Matthew whiner with
Susan Orlean next went Thursday and also
coming up conductor John McSherry dan
Rather denis leary dan Ariely
thom mayne was just with us last week
Tina Brown is with us on next Friday
Jennifer Lewis Daniel Ellsberg and we
just announced our first event for 2018
Amy Tam
tonight it's an honor to host Scott
Adams he is the cartoonist many of you
know him from the comic strip Dilbert
he's the author of several bestsellers
the Dilbert principle dogbert's top
secret management handbook and how to
fail at almost everything and still win
big he's the co-founder of when hub calm
he worked for 16 years as a technology
in technology for a major bank and then
a phone company and then as when he
started the column interviewing him
tonight is Terrence McNally who's been
on our stage several times as a
strategic communications consultant who
helps organizations tell better stories
he's been a longtime host of a favorite
show of mine here at locally on KPFK
called free forum and now he hosts a
podcast for the Wyss Institute for
Biological inspired engineering at
Harvard Scott Adams new book is win big
Lee persuasion in a world where facts
don't matter a year to today the
election outcome was predicted by lots
of people differently but not scott
adams so he has a lot to share about
that and the whole world of persuasion
I'm going to invite Scott Adams and
Terrance McNally to our stage they'll
chat for about 40 45 minutes then it'll
be your turn to ask questions please
welcome Terrance McNally and Scott
[Applause]
just look like a hostile crowd to you I
can't tell ya well this part is this
part of town they're at least curious
it's not friendly I want to start by
saying on November 11th three days after
the election I wrote of Trump and his vo
to voters he spoke directly to people
who wanted to be seen and heard he aimed
his campaign and his message at them
there was facts were wrong his story was
right
I imagined a trump supporter so now I've
got a major political candidate talking
to me and he's not just a nerdy
politician he's a macho successful
celebrity billionaire businessman and TV
star and he understands me he respects
me he cares about me and you want to
base your whole campaign on running him
down telling me he's not good enough to
be President where have I heard that
before not good enough and several
minutes into the first debate with
Hillary I turned to my wife and I said
we're in trouble
he's a narrative machine and from that
night forward I knew Trump's election
was a serious possibility Scott Adams
looking at the man in his campaign from
a highly informed perspective so much
more than I did
Adams calls Trump the most persuasive
human being he's ever observed and he
predicted Trump's win was 98% certain a
week after Nate Silver said he had a 2%
chance and as Ted said in his latest
book win big Lee Adams not only offers a
look at the persuasion strategies that
Trump used but he goes beyond politics
to look at persuasive strategies that
can work for you anywhere I won't do the
bio cuz Ted just did but Scott as I
mentioned you backstage I like listeners
to get a feel for the people not just
the book or the ideas so tell us a
little bit about how you see your path
which is
is not a normal one by any means you
mean the path to cartooning the path to
well know you start in you're working in
tech and corporations and then you
diverge into cartooning and and
somewhere there's hypnotism well I'll
give you the the fast-forward version at
the age of six I saw my first peanuts
cartoon book and I couldn't read yet but
I said finally a reason to know to learn
to read I want to know what this is all
about and about that age I decided to
become a famous cartoonist because I
thought well I saw other jobs the farmer
you know the old man I was like those
don't look nearly as good as this so
let's see if I can do that but around
about the age of eleven you become
rational and you say wait there are five
billion people or whatever there were at
the time only one Charles Schulz I don't
like my odds right so I put that on hold
for many years did the corporate rube
work for a big bank a number of jobs
worked at the phone company did a number
of jobs and when my career stalled at
both of those places
now that enough time is going by I can
tell you the real reason that my career
stalled in both places at the bank my
boss called me in one day and there was
an opening for a promotion and I was
sort of the obvious person for it I was
kind of an up-and-comer you know it was
working on my MBA and everything and she
said I don't know how to tell you this
but the company is getting in a lot of
heat because we have no diversity and
senior management and she said until
further notice we can't promote you
because you're a white male and I said
well how long is that going to last
well how long did it take us to get to
this point you know it is it's not going
to be fast so I I started looking for a
new job right away thinking you know
okay you know I'm not gonna let that
slow me down went to the phone company
and work there it got in the fast track
was recognized as a up-and-comer and one
day my boss called me into his office he
said the local newspapers all over us
they just discovered we have
diversity in senior management and will
we just can't promote you I don't know
when that's going to change now I know
what you're thinking you're thinking
that was a bad day for me right but
you'd be wrong because it turns out that
the day you find out that your effort
and your reward are not related it
really frees up your schedule so so
suddenly I had time for working on side
projects and I thought well let's see if
I could have a comic published somewhere
and I asked for some advice from a
cartoonist I seen on TV he sent me some
advice he said it's a tough business but
here's some tips where to send your
comics that sort of thing send out some
comics in some magazines they were
rejected immediately I gave up a year
later I get a letter from the same
cartoonist Jack Casady was his name and
he said he was cleaning his office came
across my letter that was still in the
pile and he said he was just writing to
make sure that I hadn't given up what I
mean that's a that's an important moment
yeah it was it was the only point of the
letter there was nothing else in it
and I had given up so I took my
materials up and I decided to raise my
sights and try to become a famous
cartoonist and newspapers all over the
world and I created Dilbert
so that was the beginning of Dilbert
we're still Burt originally multi-panel
yeah well when I set it to magazines I
single paneled it right that's what I
was thinking at and then it became three
a lot of cartoonists do four panels but
I was also a trained economist and I
think that's that's one third harder
than my three panel idea and then
fast-forward you know work for the phone
company while doing Dilbert until it
took off and then it was 2015 and I'm
sitting in front of my TV like everybody
else and I'm seeing this orange ball of
fury
it was just got everybody jabbering
I started to notice because I have a
background as a hypnotist so I'm a
trained him a trained hypnotist but let
me ask can I was curious you mentioned
I'm a hypnotist
when when was that high school junior
high later when did you early 20s and I
was influenced by my mother who was
hypnotized to give birth to my younger
sister and my mother reported that she
was you know awake and aware used no
painkillers and had a painless delivery
and I thought well what is this super
power what you know I gotta learn about
this now it turns out that maybe one in
five people could have that kind of
effect most people can't she just
happened to be one of them but I thought
I gotta learn what this superpower is to
add it to my added to my other resources
and so I mean I interrupted you but so
being a trained hypnotist how that
people might not make the immediate
connection how that you know immediately
leads to your interpretation if you will
the way that you saw Donald Trump so on
top of hypnosis I had also studied
persuasion in all of its forms
you know from communicating everything
from listening to design to to writing
and it helps in my work the Dilbert
comic is designed with persuasion
mechanics and I could talk about that
later but when I saw Trump I didn't know
that much about him you know I knew his
public figure but I hadn't seen seen
much of him and I quickly noticed that
he was using what I call weapons-grade
persuasion the type of thing that was
essentially he was bringing a
flamethrower to a stick fight and there
were no sticks that could see it it was
it was like his hands were like this but
there was nothing in them it's like hey
watch this
yeah because if you don't study it you
don't notice it
it just looks random it looks crazy it
looks provocative and you say well this
guy could never get elected with all
this crazy random provocative behavior
and I'm looking at it and saying oh my
god that's perfect
and it was so consistent yeah as I said
my analysis was on the narrative
story thing because that's what I look
for I consult organizations about story
and I just saw this guy everything is a
story let me talk just a little bit more
about Dilbert because I'm sure there are
some people that that that are here
partially at least because of that how
do you write Dilbert well it's changed
over the years I used to do one a day
and do it on paper with a pencil and
then ink over it with a pen and take it
down to the post office with which
worked until the post office figured out
where I was and then they just steal
them which actually was a common problem
for for cartoonists in those days was
they figured out what you were they're
like these will disappear but now I do a
Wacom Cintiq it's a big computer screen
that's made for drawing with a stylus so
I have I got a hand problem that caused
me to move to it but it probably reduced
my workload by 70% the I mean they're
there the drawings are simple the words
the exchanges are the juice they're do
you write them out how's the house the
you know what I'm saying the writing and
the drawing was absolutely so in the
early days I would write a sentence draw
it right draw and I didn't know where it
was going or how it was going to end and
and that ended up being almost a
trademark approach because it violated
what was the the standard da da da da da
punchline you know and so and it turned
out to be the beginning of what I would
call the the age of realism being humor
because if you look at humor it's
changed over the years from you know
vaudeville punchline II stuff and then
the seventies it was SNL it's like can
we say masturbation a TV that's funny
because because it was just violating
you know expectations but if you look at
what qualifies as humor today and really
for the last you know number of years
it's reality we watch reality TV shows -
laughs we watched Paulette
how many of you have laughed watching
the news right uuuu watch it like it's
it's almost designed as humor because
it's so often funny yeah so that's what
we see this is human now anyway so so
currently I'm more likely to write in
first and then draw a second but it's
it's evolved over time right and in case
you're wondering he wrote a few ahead so
he could be here with us yeah there are
no blank spaces in your and so you
talked about how that how the technology
has changed and so on um how has the
culture in the strip changed as the
economy goes up and down as tech goes up
and down what are some things about that
little world that lives inside those
panels well it changes with society
right so I'm trying the mirror society
and in the 90s the the bosses had all
the power and you know they were firing
people so you're just scrambling to keep
your job but now if you're an engineer
like Dilbert is and his co-workers they
have more power so they're much more
insolent and more likely to insult their
boss to his face because it's they're
hard to replace
so I move with the times okay so now
we're gonna switch to win Bigley you're
sitting there in 2015 he comes down the
escalator you watch a couple of debates
probably and sudden or even rallies and
and you see this thing how soon did you
know this was something you had to write
about and then how soon would you know
it might even be a book well I I can't
remember exactly what keep me off but I
remember that the two big confirmation
points one was the first debate where he
got the question from megyn kelly that
about his comments and about women any
normal politician dies that day that
that's that's the kill shot it's over it
doesn't matter what you say you can't
apologize you can't explain it away it's
over and what does he do
oh by the way let me just cut him for a
second if people remember that wasn't
the big grabbing line that was just
you've called them pigs
you've called them yeah I'm just setting
the right so bad that's back in 2015
August I think and what does he do
instead of engaging in like a normal
human being he cuts her off and he goes
only Rosie O'Donnell the room erupts
right so remember his base had a real
strong feeling about Rosie O'Donnell but
here's the first confirmation point it's
visual all right that was the first
thing I saw
wait this is visual he took all of our
energy from the question to the answer
and the genius was it wasn't an answer
it wasn't even the answer to the
question but you almost didn't care
because it was so entertaining your your
energy just moved there now know if
you're wondering well was that just a
lucky play I remind you you may not have
seen this but there was an interview
many months later with Chris Cuomo and
on CNN and he asked him another gotcha
question that was just as good it was an
impossible trap here was the question
imagine how you would answer this
he said the Pope has said some bad
things about capitalism you know what do
you say to the Pope now what's he do say
bad things about capitalism well he's
running for president the United States
no say bad things about the Pope when
you're running for president no there's
no way out so what does he say I tell
the Pope to worry about Isis taking over
the Vatican right what was the question
I don't know you never go back to the
question it didn't matter yet again as
visual it's provocative it takes your
energy but before that answer the
question that the second real
confirmation was the low low energy job
right I I was that I felt I was a little
bit out on the line because I started
writing about his powers of persuasion
based on the first clues but you know it
could have been wrong I mean maybe Locke
kind of it may be luck you never know
but by the time you got to a low energy
jab and that's just so engineered
compared to regular insults and I could
talk about that later or now if you're
like but that was deep technique which
would be invisible to the audience
people who haven't had that that
training they wouldn't see how much goes
into though they're not random at all so
let's let's talk about that so let me
contrast it to the bad attempts that
people use about him one of the ones
that these somebody on the Clinton side
came up with was dangerous Donald
problem his his supporters wanted a
dangerous candidate then what did
somebody who would beat Isis hard
somebody who would drain the swamp
danger was too easy to flip to a
positive they also tried this is my
favorite cheeto Jesus remember that one
which is hilarious it's you know it's
demeaning to you know mocks him but
here's a problem people like Cheetos and
they like and they love their Jesus they
love their Jesus you put those together
cheeto in Jesus and I want to buy a bag
right and so so both of those have the
quality that there was something
positive or something you can turn
around now look at his low-energy jab
can't turn that into a positive and the
moment you heard it you said that's an
unusual thing to say in the context of
politics and watch how often he uses
something that's just out of at a place
that is part of technique he is
consistently operating in this thin band
of wrongness not now so bad that he must
be executed you know not you know he's
not gonna get impeached it's just always
a little not what a president should say
you know and so that's the first thing
he puts in this technique it's a little
bit wrong so you can't look away then he
builds him for a confirmation bias later
and in this case also contrast because
he had this high energy campaign before
you heard that you probably thought this
is this Jeb Bush guy he looks like a
calm collected executive kind of the
perfect person you'd want in an
emergency yeah yeah I could see that
guy's president the moment you heard low
energy and you realize it was comparison
to high energy Trump you never could see
him the same again it was over and same
with his other nicknames crooked Hillary
once he laid laid that honor you could
guarantee something would come up about
the foundation or
the email server doesn't matter if any
of its true
it didn't matter you would be you would
be drawn to that nickname and it would
be reinforcing when you say it it
doesn't matter you'd be drawn how
broadly do you mean that in other words
do you have to be somewhat inclined
toward him to for it to really work or
will it sort of work with everybody well
in the context of a presidential race
you're gonna get something like 50/50 no
matter what right that's that's the part
where you know facts don't matter right
it's not a start there yeah facts don't
matter toward decisions they obviously
matter to the outcomes but if people
were really looking at facts and using
logic we'd probably have more like an
80/20 you know a 20% just aren't paying
attention but the other the others got
it right so really you're trying to
persuade maybe 2 percent of the public
who can be persuaded the people who have
not you know locked down a commitment
over 18 months and will you have the
best persuader the world may have ever
seen and I know not everybody's buying
into this concept yet but but trust me
or as he says it's true it's true if
you've got 18 months to work on the
public and you have non-stop coverage
you're gonna get that done and that's
what happened okay um and by the way you
didn't as I pointed out you didn't just
say you predicted he'd win you predicted
that there was a 98% chance he would win
and how early did you do that I
referenced it tonight silver but how
early was that was 2015 okay it was
early you got that it was it was at the
same time you said the two percent now I
also am trained in persuasion have you
as you've heard why did I pick 98
percent is it because I did the math
it's because they silver said two
percent and you couldn't you couldn't
you couldn't get that connection out of
your head and I also intentionally tied
my reputation to the most-respected you
know predictor in the field so that it
was easy to imagine us at the same time
and I would
some of his goodness on me right right
in other words you this was new business
for you and so you bask in the the
sentences that say 98 when he says to I
I often say that one of the tells you
know one of the signals for someone
who's trained in persuasion is that they
can change fields without practice you
can become president without being a
candidate without being a politician he
became a reality TV star without any
practice Steve Jobs didn't go to college
he formed you know Apple Computer and
then a few other businesses that also
succeeded so the the people who have
persuasion talent tend to be fluid
across fields in a way that other people
are not let me ask you this I'm as I
said I mean from as I watched him I was
both mesmerised horrified impressed all
of that with with what he was able to do
including appending peoples worldviews I
mean he was he would say you yesterday
you thought this is the way the world
work this is the way you thought
politics work this is the way you
thought candidates work and so even if
he lost his persuasion abilities would
be worth a book it wouldn't sell as well
obviously but I also believe that a
marginally smarter campaign in the Rust
Belt might have beaten it and what
happens to your prediction of 98 present
then I wouldn't be here yeah full-time
Dilbert I'm not stupid
so you know it was the sort of thing
that if I'd been wrong I would have been
embarrassed for a year and you know I
would live through it
but I have an unnatural ability to deal
with shame it's it's a it's a practice
skill you know I mean I could disrobe in
front of this I'm not going to do it but
you know I was like everybody else with
a normal sense of embarrassment but but
it's actually a learned skill that you
can actually you know treating it out of
yourself so what I hear there is you're
complimenting him as the master but
you're in choosing the book in choosing
the 98% in going out on a limb you're
following me
the same techniques yeah I consider
myself a commercial-grade persuader
meaning meaning I use it in my work and
I contrast that to say a cognitive
scientist who if you hear anybody say
that I got something wrong and they're a
cognitive scientist don't believe me
believe the cognitive scientist and then
above the cognitive scientist are the
master persuaders who were bringing a
full package there's something about
their personality their risk-taking you
know there's something bigger than just
the the persuasion skills and you you
Steve Jobs you you refer to but you say
you know that that notion that he has a
distortion field around which is what
they've said about him that to you is
the description of a master persuasion
yeah if you hear anybody has a reality
distortions field they have skills and
jobs had them do you
once you're focused on this you're
thinking about it you're blogging about
it you're writing about it
did you then go back and try to figure
out how did this happen did you know in
other words how did he become a master
persuader yeah a lot of people don't
know his pasture when he was a kid was
norman vincent peale and he had you know
a close connection to the most
motivational best-selling author who
wrote the power of positive thinking and
he really was the the person in America
who brought that idea that you could
think your way to a better situation
that that there was something about the
way you framed your existence that would
make you more effective and you see that
in Trump for example the other day my
favorite example he was he was in an
interview and he said well we had 3% GDP
that was great but without the hurricane
it probably would have been 4% I think
well that will have 4% pretty soon now
this a normal president would say hey we
got three percent right it was great
but he's already talked the economy into
four percent and who's watching the
people invest the people invest is like
yeah maybe four percent I better start
investing and that's what makes it 4% he
was actually norman vincent peale
the whole economy because the economy
moves on psychology because there's no
resource shortage here right
so he had that going he had a father was
a successful businessperson probably
knew negotiating probably saw it
firsthand he wrote a book is this Trump
on negotiating which is the artist vigil
obviously he knows branding he knows
sales
he knows marketing he has a sense of
humor these are all related he's a great
communicator he's quick on his feet he's
even he's even tall he's got something
going on up here
yeah you can't look away watch how many
persuaders have something weird going on
up there and since I don't know if it's
a coincidence but so yeah he asleep akka
John top of his personality and just his
size there's nothing it does I mean for
a long time reading your book actually
made me stop and think about this
because I've often thought he was sort
of a savant that he just you know my god
I watch him play a crowd and it's like
where did you get that but you're saying
norman vincent peale
and and and you're guessing that to
become what he's become he's been
working at this
yeah it's if you write a book about how
to negotiate it's important to you
yeah that's it scorches is being let me
ask about Bernie Sanders Bernie Sanders
drew crowds at least his biggest Trump's
he elicited the similar kind of passion
and loyalty and I'd say two things he
does that I find effective is he does
deal in narratives he really does
there's a narrative of class and history
and all of that he comes across as very
authentic in contrast to most
politicians in fact rough sort of in his
them you know he's not polished but he
doesn't seem to me to be the persuader
Trump is what's what's your how do you
see well you know under Brazil probably
has a better answer for what happened to
Bernie but wouldn't you agree let's poll
the audience wouldn't you agree that
Bernie outperformed compared to what you
expected when you say yes now and did
you notice me
and that Hillary Clinton's persuasion
game was pathetic until he dropped down
did you notice that that that she got
weapons-grade over the summer the final
summer there was just a real change and
it happened instantly she went from let
me tell you about my boring policy and I
checked my website I'm not even really
gonna tell you about it and then she
went to he's dark you know he's going to
destroy the world with nuclear weapons
she wouldn't fear which is your ultimate
persuasion and that word dark as soon as
I saw it and all the pundits had gotten
the memo when they all started using
he's it's a dark speech after the
Republican convention dark dark dark I
said I think I know who's advising her
and I think he was advising Bernie
before because remember Bernie had the
the most award-winning campaign ad it
was the one where it was a Simon and
Garfunkel's on America you have people
screaming like I got chills when I
watched it that was so good and and he
had all the game and then suddenly she
went from nothing to something and I
speculated that the one of the greatest
persuaders of all time may have joined
her team after leaving the the sinking
Bernie ship I had been calling him
Godzilla in my blogs sort of that deep
throat like that because I didn't want
to name him right that wasn't sure right
but I thought I saw the fingerprint on
the work and I had seen a book called
pre suasion before most people had from
Robert Jill Dini the person who wrote
influenced the most influential book
about how to influence and persuasion
talked about things like using that word
dark they would just prime you to see
things in a different way and I thought
I see his fingerprint and so finally I I
finally said it publicly and there was I
sent it to a reporter at one point and
he tracked him down and asked for a
comment and SME are you consulting for a
Clinton and his comment was no comment
now if you're not consulting for
Tocantins yeah do you say no comment
well thanks though and then some of his
associates confirmed that he in fact was
now keep in mind I picked that up from
one word because that word was so well
chosen yeah and I recognize it from his
writing I had an advance copy of his
book which was a mistake for him because
I I caught him but but I think people
who had the same training I had could
have also recognized it so it wasn't
magic it was a result of training but I
mean did some of the things that I saw
in Burnie probably you know with or
without children II the the sort of raw
authentic passionate I mean does does
that does that fall into how does that
fall into persuasion those sorts of
qualities you know that working against
him he didn't have a good physical the
visual wasn't good you know yet his hair
was always you know some version well
but the hair the crazy hair sometimes
yeah yeah baby needed to be a little
crazier or more Orange but yeah you know
his biggest secret was he was promising
people free money for nothing you know
and you don't have to be the best
persuader in the world if you say free
college you can't really get young
people at it to rally free it free
healthcare free college you're gonna get
some energy but yeah obviously had a
good advisor okay um let me I've got
lots of questions let me ask one right
now it seems if I watch Trump right now
that his most successful moves are
executive orders and choosing a Supreme
Court justice neither of which call for
much persuasion
who is he persuading these days besides
his base we'll keep in mind he didn't
get to do those things you mentioned
until he persuaded enough people to
become presence right who is he
persuading now how is it working for him
now
so so now it's a whole different bag of
persuasion so he has to keep persuading
his base even the Republican senators
who hate
and can't stop talking about you know
what a bad person is when you say but
are you going to vote for the things he
wants to oh yeah we're gonna vote for
him sure you know we're gonna vote his
way so he has the entire Republican side
pretty much you know dancing the way he
in some sense because of his base as
long as his base is passionate they're
skinny now if we go on a point-by-point
level just mentioned a few how is he
persuading Isis now compare President
Obama's approach which was hey we're
gonna leave an X date which just
persuades Isis to to stay around we just
wait them out Trump came in it's that
bad persuasion we're gonna say we're
here forever and we're not gonna just
chase you we're gonna destroy you and
we're seeing the first like surrenders
you know they used to fight to the death
now we don't know if that's a trend yet
but we're seeing him and Isis has
largely been wiped out part of the
persuasion was the way he treated the
military he said madis you know how to
do this I don't figure it out
and I would expect that the morale of
the the military who were actually you
know in the fight over there probably
the best that's ever been
that's persuasion so Isis is a
successful persuasion certainly the
economy he has talked up yes Obama is
responsible for seventy-five percent of
the good times I give him a solid grade
Obama was great he was a master
persuader yeah he was the right person
in the right time in 2009 when things
were going to hell you don't want the
orange haired guy alright you don't want
the flame thrower you want the lawyer
who says it's gonna be okay I've looked
into it I'm gonna make this work so he
gets credit for the strong base but
clearly there's a trump bump to the
economy and that that has everything to
do with his persuasion okay so now
you've got Isis and the economy
those are both directly and I think
pretty demonstrably true that persuasion
is a big part of that now he's in China
China loves him they love him he's a
rock star over there he clearly is
persuading and it works both ways right
you know she is persuading him he's
swinging them back but they have this
lovely dance just at the time that this
alliance is crucial to deal with North
Korea let's talk about North Korea are
they persuaded well I've got a feeling
that little rocket man for the first
time doesn't know if he'll be alive in a
month that has never been the case
before I would guess and that does make
a difference unlike his brother yeah you
don't want to be so I would say there's
there's maybe for the first time yeah a
chance that something could happen in
North Korea if you can't China's
persuasion that's moving in the right
direction with the economy so that's
looking good what other topics you got I
mean I guess you could have health care
or our tax cut so let's talk about
health care so health care you notice he
stood back and let Congress take the
lead he basically didn't persuade not
really I mean he didn't put any effort
into it he didn't even care what it was
you said bring something to my desk
you've had years to work on this where
the hell's by bill he said Republicans
I'm the guy who signs it all right my
part I can do my part you just bring me
some like inside and they didn't but the
only way you're ever gonna get a health
care bill is the way he played it which
is let the Republicans go first within a
big majority fail hard try again fail
hard realize they have no hope meanwhile
scare the pants off the left because
they're watching what the Republicans
have in mind is like no not that and
then what does he do when they failed
and these guys are scared he says maybe
I should talk to the Democrats I you
know if you're if you're saying to
yourself you know he hasn't gotten
health care done in the time you hoped
it would be done true enough
all right but was there a deadline for
that he's letting the Obamacare fail
that's part of the persuasion he's
taking it to the end until the way he's
sabotaging it yes yes so essentially
he's making things worse until there's
desperation
and people are ready for somebody to
come in and say look the only way this
works is if you guys meet in the middle
and you've never been willing to do that
until then and are you guessing that if
I mean he can't predict exactly how all
this is going to play out if it looked
like health care was the most important
issue in a lot of the elections that
Democrats won this week where it used to
be an anchor it's now an asset if that
plays out in 2018 and it isn't a
Republican you know a good Republican
midterm it's a good Democrat midterm in
some sense there's that thing you talked
about two ways to win no way to lose I
have a feeling I always have this
feeling that that's ultimately where he
is his brand survives no matter what
happens to the Republicans well I think
he's actually going to come out ahead if
he gets a mixed Congress I think the
surprise would be if if the Democrats
had some big wins and you know the
Republicans lost the majority at least
one of the one of the places I think
he'd have a better chance of negotiating
something in the middle I don't think
that's worse for him because the worst
case is a Republican majority shoving
something down the throats of the left
and the rest of the country yeah nobody
can really be comfortable with that you
need somebody to come on the other side
yeah interesting um let me get back to
sort of the foundation of this you write
this one line I pulled out humans think
they are rational and they think they
understand their reality they are wrong
on both counts
and it was my sense that that humans
think they're rational they're wrong
they think they understand the reality
they're wrong is the foundation for
everything else in this book yeah one of
the things you learn as a hypnotist is
that the common view of the world is
exactly upside down and what I mean is
that the common view is that humans are
rational creatures we use reason we look
at facts maybe 90% of the time 10% of
the time we get a little crazy but you
know we figure out that doesn't happen
to us that's other people the hypnotist
turns that around and says we are
irrational ninety percent of the time
and don't know it because we're
rationalizing you have
the fact and only 10% in like little
ridiculous things like balancing your
checkbook or searching for the best
price online that's rational there's no
emotional content but until you
understand that we're irrational you
can't even be a hypnotist because
nothing would make sense the things you
do would have known logical but you
can't believe it's going to work now I
learned this you know many decades ago
before there was scientific backing for
it so it was sort of taken that the
hypnotist just say just act like it's
true and watching what happens right
that they didn't try to you know put a
science on it but now there's books like
knowledge influenced breathe you know
pre suasion there's tons of science
showing that humans don't use rational
thought to make decisions and you can
see it yourself if half the country is
going to go the way they're going to go
no matter who runs yeah how much fact
and logic is in any of those decisions
you know we if you go to the grocery
store there's people with five different
you know religions shopping next to you
some think they reincarnate had some
things are gonna live forever so think
there's no heaven these are completely
different realities but yeah they could
all buy groceries they can all procreate
so it turns out the evolution never
cared if you actually understood your
reality you dunder it cared if you could
make more of yourself and now that was a
very low bar
you you certainly say as he said to you
folks he said if you read something that
a cognitive scientist or an evolutionary
psychologist says that it differs from
when I say then trust them are there any
in particular that you recommend but I
mean besides if they were to read
something else in this realm
besides wind Bigley um yeah if you just
google the phrase persuasion reading
list you will come up with my list it's
the first search term so persuasion
reading list and so a bunch of
persuasion related books okay very good
let me ask you about a couple of the
things that we may have mentioned or may
not but falling from that fact that
we're not rational and so on one of the
key things you've mentioned confirmation
bias
what is confirmation bias and an example
so confirmation bias is the human
tendency to think that all evidence
supports your preconceived notion right
so we're watching the the Russia stuff
you know there's there's some Hillary
stuff then there's some Trump stuff
depending on which side you're on you're
gonna believe that all the stuff on the
other side is definitely true and all
the stuff on about your candidate well
that can be true that's just crazy and
you know it has nothing to do with the
facts because we really don't have
access to the facts of any done stuff
but we did but I think lest anyone think
that this is when you're looking at
politics this is what we do when we're
in June we're in high school and we
think a girl likes us or we don't right
I mean it's like yeah I mean it's
everything isn't it yeah once you
realize it's not the exception
it's I've talked about that and
cognitive dissonance as essentially the
operating system for the human mind
these are not the flaws in the operating
system this is the operating system okay
this is our normal yeah yeah cognitive
dissonance so cognitive dissonance is
almost hard to believe if you haven't
been exposed to it but I think after you
know after the the Trump experience most
people have heard the the term refers to
the fact that if something violates your
sense of
what is true especially if it's about
yourself you will instantly rewrite the
movie in your head to reinterpret it and
sometimes ridiculously so until until
it's just something that other people
will look at and say well I think you've
lost that you are now crazy but the
person the first news in it thinks it's
perfectly rational it only looks crazy
on the outside now again if you think
well that sounds like a terrible thing
to happen to other people you're missing
the point but an example in in in in not
in the campaign but in her own life of
cognitive dissonance so if you knew say
a cigarette smoker who's you saying hey
why don't you quit smoking now people
don't like to think of themselves as
having no willpower they don't like to
think of themselves as not being aware
of the science that it's going to kill
you so you get crazy answers like well I
knew somebody who smoked three packs a
day and made a you know 15 barbecues and
dragged 10 beers and lift 110 so yeah
got it
you you mentioned this thing about
visual persuasion is that that if you
can say something which makes something
appear in someone else's mind's eye if
you will this is if a picture is worth a
thousand words a visual piece of
persuasion is worth a thousand words
yeah so if you were to rank the
different types of persuasion
you know if fear is always the top
because you know if you don't take care
of your fear you can't really do
anything else but within the the non
fear categories visual persuasion is
very powerful and it's powerful because
we're visual creatures so the visual
part of mind just just sort of overrules
the other parts so look at imagine if if
candidate Trump did not have this visual
persuasion and he was describing border
security he might have said yes well
we'd like tighter border security we're
going to use a variety of means depends
on the terrain in some terrain
this and sub train we do that no he said
we're building a wall right we all see a
wall as soon as he says that we're all
twirled we're all presenting big
beautiful right and then it gets better
more more technique he says and I'm
gonna make Mexico pay for all right now
again it's a it sees and then narrow
band of wrongness you go well that's
wrong you know that can't be right but
maybe well it's wrong but maybe and and
so you obsess on it and while you're
thinking about the question of you know
we're now arguing about who's gonna
build a wall yeah once you argue about
who's paying for it here you have
uncritically you somewhat accepted well
there's gonna be some kind of wall how
the hell are we paying for that thing
and you'll see him use that technique a
lot you know it's it's making you think
past the sale is the technique so by the
way in the book as I said at the top
these things are laid out like this so
you can get it you can stew about the
campaign you can get either excited or
fume or whatever you want but he also
was delivering for you how you can use
these same techniques try to make it
useful yes in your in your own life um
one thing that I found curious was you
site sense of humor as one of his assets
one of his talents and yet I've heard a
number of people say I don't think I've
ever seen him laugh
what's going on there I heard somebody
say that and I think I might have said
it somewhere on a periscope or something
and immediately said people send me
links of him laughing but it's rare
considering how much we've seen him on
screen
perhaps in public it is rare yeah but
but nobody has that fine a sense of
humor and also doesn't laugh that would
be very unusual like yeah and the sense
of humor is in things like the Rosie
O'Donnell line was just came I mean an
improv couldn't come up with it quicker
so so one thing that people don't
understand about her sense of humor and
I feel like I have a little advantage
there because I grew up in upstate New
York and there's there's definitely a
regional sense of humor there are things
that New Yorkers would say and do there
would be appalling two Californians so
so having seen both worlds you know
a flavor that my favorite example was
the the John McCain joke I prefer people
don't get caught now with all due
respect to the people in the military
and the veterans I don't mean any
disrespect but that is a a well-known
joke form you know it's it's but he was
simply reminded of a common joke and
what makes that funny to the people who
let him find it funny the people the
people who laughed at home because you
don't write you don't laugh in front of
other people that's right that what
makes it funny is the wrongness of it
all right so the people who are laughing
that are not laughing at McCain they're
not laughing at veterans they're
laughing at how completely wrong that
was to say and he knew that it was wrong
when he said it that's why it was funny
it was completely a bad move like that
that was you know I don't count that in
his his wins on the procession front
that was just a mistake
he does have some mistakes but it was
based on that I think in a blind spot
because in New York it's a little
funnier than it is in California right
one thing I found interesting he Scott
talks about his own just sort of at the
very upfront he says well this is sort
of my politics and and another
interesting one for me what I don't
think we'll get into is these are my
filters I found that very interesting
so we're forget a second after I ask you
this one let me ask you about those
filters because it is fascinating but
you said you don't vote
why not wholly correct so when you learn
persuasion one of the things that you
learn and and this is one of the
stronger effects is as soon as you join
a team you vote for the team and you
start confirmation bias will make you
think that everything the team does is
smart and brilliant so I try to keep
myself unaligned from from an
identifiable team to try to preserve
what little I can of my objectivity
now I'm not blind to the fact that I am
a human being and therefore I may have
been you know an exaggerated sense of
how objective I can be but I do what I
can right there are things you can do to
at least try to be objective
and that's one of them well but I'm
having a I'm gonna press you on there
because it doesn't seem to me that
voting even says you're on a team it
says that when it came down to it that
day you know you made a choice but it
doesn't mean I mean but you don't want
your choice to do poorly you know your
but by the time you've made your
decision
way ahead of time all right now likewise
because I will say you're saying that
the act of voting is not it it's that
once you're in that mode as you said
you're sort of rooting you begin to very
few people made up their mind in the
voting booth oh this happened yeah long
before that so yeah that you're you're
reinforcing your bias for months and
months before then so would we have a
problem if everyone began to go I want
to be objective in this well if nobody
else voted I would vote because boy that
yeah the value of your vote would go way
up yeah um I found one interesting
statistic Trump won 49 to 29 among those
who didn't like either candidate that's
a huge victory what does that have to do
with persuasion so this is the the first
president whose popularity you know when
they do the polls you know or approval
let's use the approval whose approval
may forever stay in the toilet while
people's assumption about how he's doing
in the job could float much higher
there's going to be this huge disconnect
we already see it because you see for
example consumer confidence and Wall
Street confidence the stock market there
are people who are judging the biggest
issues as being quite competent but when
they look at the approval that they say
do you approve of them and they think of
something he said that was you know
unkind it was over-the-line and they say
I can't approve of that I like my 401 K
you know but that's a separate question
his incompetence and I'll put it in
quotes since we don't say agree on that
couldn't that be what buffers us from
the effects of what we don't approve of
in other words if he doesn't really get
anything done then the stock market
might as well
what it does because he's not as
relevant as if he were well
micromanaging well keep in mind and this
is this is a fascinating thing if if I
have a conversation with someone who is
a very anti Trumper I can say they can
say you know what has he done and I'll
make a list that's this long and a
minute and a half later that person who
just saw the list will say but he hasn't
gotten anything done and and I think
that that's my perfect example of what I
call the the two movies on one screen we
literally are seeing a different movie
even though we're sitting the same
theater and I had predicted over a year
ago that the way that this year would
play out is it would start on
Inauguration Day with my god we've
elected Hitler it's Hitler its Hitler
well you know march in the streets it's
terrible but after a few months of no
Hitler stuff you know just being sort of
a normal president people would say all
right he didn't he didn't round up
anybody and put them in concentration
camps it doesn't look like anything like
that's gonna happen
but he's totally incompetent so they
changed the next thing he's incompetent
there's chaos but after the summer and
we start to see some accomplishments
you know Isis the economy maybe maybe
some movement with North Korea
Healthcare still gonna be problematic
but people think that's Congress you
know in our minds we think that's a
little more of a partly by the way he
dealt with it yes yeah yeah but at the
end of the year all the news
organizations are going to start putting
together their lists of what happened
and it's gonna be a long list it's
you're not gonna like it because it's
gonna be Republican stuff and if you're
not one you're gonna say well I don't
like that stuff but it's gonna be a long
list and that will be really interesting
and I predicted that by that time people
would say all right he did get a lot
done
he was effective but we don't like the
things he's doing you know we don't like
the regulations he's cut but he did cut
a lot of them right and and that's stuff
Republican what we're doing right now
just as I watch it's that the
appointments he made of people you know
who wanted to do away with the agencies
they're running are doing that that's I
mean that will make up a great deal of
the long list
is that well yeah Pruitt's doing and
Perry's doing and so on and so on yeah
you know it's interesting how many
executive orders he's signed that I
don't see a lot of analysis of all the
damage it's doing now I assume that
they're not all good I mean on paper
some of them look like really bad ideas
too you know that to get rid of this
regulation or this protection and you
know on the surface they don't look like
good ideas but you also don't hear the
counterpoint well he's getting nerdy but
partially it's that an executive order
only starts the ball rolling the actual
you know that's one of the things about
the wonderful flourish when you hold it
up it says if it's done in fact all that
does is it begins to move some levers
and the bad effects or good effects
aren't going to show up for months or
years and so on Ted are we about ready
to go to questions okay I will let Ted
take it from here so time for questions
the rules around here our questions
generally start with a W or an H
sometimes a D they are typically short
there is no such thing as a two-part
question and only Terrance McNelly
tonight gets to ask follow-up questions
thank you Scott
question on Godzilla you say that you
think she'll Dini was helping Hillary
but you never mentioned did he stop hell
not helping Hillary I don't understand
if he was helping did it stop at some
point because we didn't see the let's
say the wave overcome Donald Trump so
could you comment on that well you know
toward the end you had two of the best
persuaders you know going going head to
head and and sometimes King Kong beats
Godzilla and I think that's what
happened I had predicted more of a
landslide kind of win by Trump and I was
actually surprised you know that it was
as close as it was but I wasn't totally
surprised because by the the summer
before the election when she started the
the dark persuasion I recognize that as
weapons-grade and I thought okay you
know now this is a whole new game if she
had kept on the way she started
let me tell you about my policies and by
the way I'm a woman you know it elected
me because I'm a woman that was just you
know that would have been a violation by
Election Day but she really she upped
her game okay next next question here on
your right thank you
hi um if we're 90 percent irrational
over here oh hi if we're 90 percent
irrational what's your irrational
thinking I don't understand that well if
we're being irrational what are you
being irrational about Oh what things in
general and my irrational doubt is that
the beauty is that the only person who
can tell is the person you ask the
question of so like if I could recognize
my own irrationality I'd say whoa better
cut this out right now yeah well let's
use some facts so no that's the
unanswerable question we're all
potentially in our own little bubble and
we can't tell what do you think Trump's
chances are in 2020 I'm not convinced he
would run in 2020 if he has a really
good four years and things are lining up
that if he gets a little motion on North
Korea maybe that looks a little better
and there's something that looks like
health care and the economy stays strong
and Isis stays beaten he's going to be
unbeatable but he also knows how to go
out on top
so given his age which is a real concern
that will only get worse you know
especially you know you'd be hitting
that that age range where it's it's hard
to believe there's not a problem right
like you know your best supporter is
going to say you know I don't know was
that clever or is that something else so
his best play to preserve the the Trump
brand and his presidency might be one
term but he's also competitive as hell
so if there's something undone that he
thinks he could do yeah he might be up
just a pit bull and just say alright
give me four in four more years I'll try
to get this other thing done so I think
maybe a 50%
even run no matter how is four years ago
I Scott thanks for coming down I just I
wanted to ask what is your technique for
looking for confirmation bias in the
news given all the fake news that keeps
coming out yeah so the first thing I do
is when I see something reported that's
you know new and you know maybe a head
scratcher I check the other networks
because the networks are pretty good at
getting the facts right right just the
basic facts what they're terrible at is
is a non biased interpretation because
they use the amount of time they spend
on one thing versus the other the number
of guests the type of guests they have
on and what those guests say so they
they bury the facts with opinion and so
I just try to sample both sides and it
really if you go between Fox News and
CNN you're changing universes like MSNBC
even more so yeah even more so so I try
to stick to the facts and see both sides
of the confirmation bias and then if I
see that there's two completely
believable interpretations look
completely different I tend not to
believe either one right because that
just tells you it's easy to come up with
any story that fits these facts which is
often the case hi Scott thanks for
coming out right here do you have any
predictions you're willing to divulge
outside of the political arena yeah so
this is probably my prediction that's
least likely to come true but I'm going
to put it out there anyway because I
think I mentioned I don't have shame
like regular people the football
kneelers I think that by the end of the
year the full season that the teams who
knelt you ever had more people kneeling
will underperform meaning that they
won't beat the spread
all right that doesn't mean the win
because the better team is still going
to usually win but I think that that's
enough of a distraction and in a mental
mental distraction first of all you
can't you can't really do two important
things at the same time your brain isn't
good
two things and the kneeling would take
you out of the football mode and put you
in sort of a whole other mode and people
are looking at you and then there's a
hatred from your own fans you know the
home court advantage is sort of
sacrificed if your fans are saying you
know I used to like football but I hate
that [ __ ] you know they're they're
just they're gonna be really angry
that's got to hurt and I also think that
there's something about the physical act
of getting on one knee that might
activate and here's the speculative part
that might activate the part of your
brain that is sort of submissive
subjugated subjugated it's like you know
the king is not the one who kneels you
know the winner is not the one who
kneels now yes I understand that is an
act of defiance and and in and in this
in this this specific context is
actually a strong feeling as an actor
here's the thing day one it's strong why
this 12 week you're just kneeling and
and here's the thing you're your body
and your brain are pretty connected you
know there's there's a research that
says if you're that if you force
yourself to smile you're your happiness
chemistry and your brain can be
activated the same way it works in
Reverse if you're happy you'll smile but
if you smile you can actually cause
yourself to be happy you know when you
just said the thing about you know I'm
jumping in here for a second but there's
one that I I wanted to ask that I forgot
which is you said the thing about you
lacking shame having trained yourself to
and and you say the same thing about
trunk one reason that he can be so wrong
is that it doesn't matter as I watch him
it seems to me he is both thin-skinned
and thick-skinned that he's both hyper
sensitive and a ball what's that about
confirmation bias here's the thing can
you imagine that he didn't know how he
would be treated when he ran for
president he made this choice to be just
you know shat upon for a year to start
out with the whole rapist thing in the
first five minutes yeah
just indicates that he knew what he was
getting into and he was okay with it
now the thing you called thin-skinned is
anytime somebody attacks him he
immediately responds that that's sort of
how you interpret this and in some sense
it seems out of proportion and why did
that you know that's just a flea why act
like it was a but here's the thing you
notice it's a at least within the
context of the campaign and through now
the people the attacks are the
professionals he's not going after a
citizen who said something on social
media
he's going after professional
journalists writers politicians and in
the case of say the cons who you know
who were part of the they were
professional by association because they
appeared they were they were
professional in that context they were
doing a political public thing for
political people the the technique here
is that I had a co-worker who became the
the model for the Alice character in my
strip who I first saw this technique
lovely let me tell you her technique and
then you'll see it in Trump if somebody
did something she wanted you know that
there was like a favor or something she
would immediately go to their boss and
say you've got the best employee
you should have promote this person
because they were doing what she wanted
you know appear right but if somebody
didn't do what she wanted she would go
to the boss and she say you got to get
rid of this idiot you know this is this
is horrible it's the worst thing get rid
of them so she would create this giant
difference the gap the contrast
everything about persuasion is contrast
right what's the bad thing what's a good
thing and she and everybody knew that
making her happy then she would give you
flowers in the office literally she'd
bring you flowers she would pray she she
would get you promoted literally she got
people promoted for doing what she
wanted and she had amazing control over
the office at the same level as her
peers because of that when Trump that
when somebody does something that Trump
likes for example when I was on CNN he
liked what I said and and apparently he
was watching from Air Force One and the
the message came through Smerconish got
the message he was the one to interview
me
and and I got the word that you liked it
and also Smerconish got the word that
that you know that he liked it or there
was watching anyway which the same thing
and so he so he complements and helps
the people who help him and he goes hard
every time every time doesn't matter if
you're Republican right doesn't doesn't
matter but if you have to be a
professional right if you see him going
after somebody said something on social
media then he got a work right because
that wouldn't be technique that would be
thin-skinned but as long as he keeps
that line I think you're okay I have
time for two more questions hi Scott
my question is how will Trump persuade
Robert Moeller well that's a good
question let me give you a related story
so you can you you can maybe fill in the
blanks here do you remember when he said
that awful thing about judge curiel and
he said you know I'm not sure
paraphrasing I don't think I'll get a
fair trial because he's Mexican and
everybody said my god what a racist he's
saying that he can't be a fair judge
because he's Mexican of course that
wasn't what was going on here's what was
going on if you talk to your neighbor
and say hey neighbor tell me a little
about yourself there's a good chance
your neighbor will say well you know
we're Italian but it means they were all
born in America they just have Italian
heritage the way people talk about
themselves is exactly the way Trump
talked about judge Curiel I was at
dinner not long ago or where a young man
said he was describing himself he said
he was Mexican you know you it's like
three generations born in this country
and he was 20% Mexican but he said I'm
Mexican it's the way people talk about
themselves so first of all he was using
a shorthand that is sort of the common
language but it was a big mistake
however by bringing up the potential
bias which is common in the legal
context very uncommon in the political
context and wrong in every way but in
the legal context which was more
important
to him at the moment bias is very
important so you pointed out and then
what happened when judge curial had to
had to rule on when the trial would be
held it could have been before the
election which would have been a
disaster and that's normally when it
would have been because there's no
reason to push it out but instead judge
curial gave him a little extra
consideration and he put it after the
election and it might have well been the
difference between winning and losing in
the election now did Judge gharial have
to do that he didn't was he treating him
like every other you know person in the
legal system I don't think so I think he
gave him a little extra you know a
little extra consideration there would
he have done that if the President had
not called them to the entire world that
list for bias that this judge might be
biased he took away his option all right
in the context of a legal case it was
brilliant in the context of the way he
worded it and in a political situation
he just looked like a damn racist right
but you know if you ask somebody like
Alan Dershowitz who was you know on the
oGH aisle among other things is bias a
legitimate thing to bring up in the
legal context you'd say hell yes that
that's my job
that that's what I do I bring up bias
all the time on every level there's
nothing off the table and certainly your
your if your entire family heritage is
in a group that you imagine there might
be some people who would not be happy
with the judge at the next Thanksgiving
you know if he's ruled in favor of Trump
that's legitimate in the legal context
it's illegitimate in almost every other
context and we would like it that way
right we don't want it to be parted so
the point is about Mueller look for
things that Trump says to be in public
to bias Mueller to make him give the the
president a little extra consideration
because he doesn't want to play into the
trap that the president is setting which
is hey I'm not sure you're being fair
here
so he's going to have to try a little
harder to look
extra fare I mean one could even say
that happened with Comey yeah not not
the firing but the coming out on October
28th with the we're looking at some new
email you could exactly say that yes the
Comey probably was persuaded to to flip
the opposite direction to go above and
beyond what he had to do so that he
because he was extra good to Clinton at
first and then he went the other way
yeah that's probably true in our final
question for the evening hi Scott up
here with your opening question when you
came out and asked if this was gonna be
a hostile audience I'm just wondering if
that was a persuasive technique it
wasn't a persuasion no I was hoping it
was going to be because a hostile
audience just has lots of energy and
remember I have no shame so it would
have been actually kind of fun I was
hoping you know for anything short of
violence to happen here today but you've
all been extra extra nice so far so I'll
tell you a funny thing we're backstage
and of course there's there's you can
when you're backstage you can hear
things in the audience and I heard it as
murmuring and you used the word that was
much more I the rumbling you know you
were already sort of putting them in
that role yeah
oh thanks Terrence thanks Scott thank
you all for coming
[Applause]
Scott has a lingering issue with his
hand so it's unable to sign books but
he's happy to pose for a photograph with
anyone who purchased the book Wow so I
will be bringing him into the lobby and
we'll do that if you drove I like to say
please go gently and perhaps we'll see
you at one of our upcoming events good
night
[Applause]